clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à benoît
[Musique]
un repas d'affaires 1 dijk un dîner en
ville une fête entre amis
dtc vous donne les moyens de briller en
société avec 8 infos sur la santé que
les gens ne connaissent pas ces cadeaux
c'est la première salve et on commence
tout de suite avec
vous connaissez la petite goutte celle
qui a tendance à finir dans le slip est
bon on va apprendre à s'en débarrasser
alors oui ça concerne plutôt les gens
qui possèdent un pénis mais si vous en
avez dans votre entourage vous pourrez
leur expliquer la petite doute quand
vous avez fini il reste coincé dans
l'urètre là au niveau de la flèche rouge
parce que vous avez vu ça fait un coude
et quand vous relâcher tout bas ça se
vide comme un tuyau d'arrosage
donc vous comprenez bien que ça sert à
rien de ce que votre truc dans tous les
sens pour la faire partir là elle est
trop loin la petite goutte ce qu'il faut
faire c'est appuyer avec votre pouce là
où il ya la flèche bleue oui entre les
roubignoles et puis vous pousser vers
l'avant pour l'expulser oui et après
vous vous lavez les mains je vais pas
tout vous dire je pas votre mère en tout
cas fait le test vous verrez ça marche
le nom de slips et dignité que je vais
sauver moi si je pouvais je me donnerai
une vague
on vous a déjà dit qu'il fallait surtout
pas boire d'alcool quand on est sous
anti bio parce que ça a dû les frais des
médicaments
bah c'est des conneries attention serait
pas dire que c'est une bonne idée de se
mettre une mine le plus souvent alcool +
antibio égale pas de souci mais y en a
avec lesquelles s'est pas conseillé
parce que ça peut donner un coup de
chaud des fois rien de méchant
des fois c'est plus vénère et s'est
jamais agréable surtout quand on est
déjà malade quand on prend un anti bio
c'est qu'on n'est pas au top et l'alcool
ça fait pas du bien de petits corps ça
déshydrate un génial et ça peut donner
la chasse comme certains anti bio double
peine pas ouf
les pixels x calvin l'alcool et pas mal
d'autres substances genre certains
antibiotiques
donc si vous buvez beaucoup d'alcool il
va pas pouvoir tout faire ça reste de
s'accumuler et ça va pas vous faire du
bien
donc si vous êtes sous anti bio et que
vous êtes obligés de boire l'apéro ça
peut arriver
buvez pas trop mais surtout avant
vérifier que l'alcool est pas des
conseillers avec ce que vous prenez
c'est hyper facile c'est marqué sur la
notice
j'ai vu ça c'est joli à cet effet une
sangsue pas n'importe quel sens su unir
udo medicine alice ou sangsue
médicinales everett une sangsue qu'on
utilise pour soigner ça s'appelle les
bus de thérapie et ça existe depuis
l'antiquité
alors qu'est ce qu'elle a de spécial
cette sangsue evala d'izieu de ventouses
trois mâchoires d'une centaine de dents
et elle a surtout de la salive et dans
sa salle il ya plus de 30 substances
actives différentes qui diminue
l'inflammation qui rendent le sens plus
liquide et qui calme la douleur donc à
l'hôpital on utilise les sangsues quand
le sang a tendance à stagner comme après
une greffe ou une réimplantation demande
en attendant que la circulation surface
normalement elle file un coup de main en
nettoyant et en inspirant tout ça c'est
facile il suffit de les poser où on veut
et quand elles ont fini leur repas quand
elles sont bien pleines de samba s était
proche tout seul voilà une sangsue ça
coûte 7 euros et on peut s'en servir
pendant plusieurs mois
est ce que c'est ce truc là tout là haut
un pignon de pin aller à demain le
groupe ok donc un pignon de pin et au
bout de la flèche c'est la glande
pinéale le plus petit organes du corps
humain
bon alors quel rapport là bas ils font
la même taille à peu près 8 mm et elle a
une forme de pomme de pain d'où son nom
mais le truc le plus dingue c'est que
cette petite crotte planqué en plein
milieu de notre cerveau là c'est la
bosse de notre rythme biologique et
notamment de notre sommeil
comment c'est possible et bah c'est elle
qui sécrète la fameuse mélatonine qu'on
appelle l'hormone du sommeil
même si bon c'est pas tout à fait ça
mais bref ce petit machin est tellement
fascinant que des cartes
le philosophe il pensait que notre âme
était dedans et si vous doublez vous
allez trouver plein de trucs genre c'est
notre troisième oeil
elle contient des cristaux qui vibre
c'est une connexion divine et c'est bon
en fait c'est juste une glande et
sécrètent des neurotransmetteurs
mais c'est déjà pas mal parce que vous
avez vu lé surpuissante
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est le
problème de ces organismes à part le
fait que manifestement leurs
propriétaires se ronge les ongles des
pieds je veux dire eh bah disons le coït
c'est désormais ico vides et alors c'est
pas très heureux qu évident c'est l'être
humain qui est juste au dessus mais ils
sont quand même atteint le fait qu'ils
soient tous rouge est tout gonflé comme
ça comme s'il y avait des engelures à
cause du froid
en fait c'est une inflammation et on a
remarqué que ça touchait un certain
nombre de malades mais on n'est pas
vraiment sûr de savoir exactement
pourquoi et apparemment ça pourrait
toucher d'autres parties du corps en
avril dernier il ya déjà des
dermatologues qui avait remarqué ça et
qui avait prévenu que c'était possible
que le coc vide donne des accrocs
syndrome oui c'est le terme scientifique
si vous voulez vous la péter handke et
la voilà ça a été de nouveau confirmé
par des médecins locaux vides a priori
peut donner ce genre d'inflammation des
orteils se louer quand même le colis de
noël ça fait perdre le goût et l'odorat
pour ça qu'ils se ronge les ongles des
pieds lui
vous savez pourquoi vos pieds simple
fromage six pompiers sans que le fromage
arrêté sur ok il ya des veaux mortes de
la sueur et une espèce de graisse qui
s'appelle le sébum et tout ça va ça fait
un petit festin pour les bactéries donc
les bactéries elles se battre et quand
elles ont bien mangé quand elles ont
fini et rejette diverses substances
comme l'acide
isobel eric qui donne cette odeur
caractéristique parmi ces bactéries en a
qui sont de la famille debré vie
bactérienne et c'est vrai dit bacterial
elles sont aussi utilisées pour
l'affinage de certains fromages comme le
maroilles le munster ou la raclette
voilà maintenant vous savez que le
fromage sans le caca de bactéries et que
c'est les mêmes bactéries que celle que
vous avez sur les pieds il me reste plus
qu'à vous souhaiter un bon appétit
j'ai remarqué que les gens qui sentent
la weed enfin leur sueur sans la weed
dans ces cas là vous vous dites
bailhache mais la weed
bah oui bah non pas sur l'odeur
corporelle c'est comme un cocktail dans
notre sport on rejette plein de
substances odorantes différentes
le cac à des bactéries qui mange notre
sueur par exemple les bayards un
chercheur qui a analysé les composants
chimiques odorant de la sueur et de la
weed
et il y en a une dizaine en comment ça
veut dire que si vous avez les 10 dans
le bon dosage pas sans le faire exprès
vous avez réussi le token par terre ça
sans pareil ça dépend de plein de choses
dans ça dépend des bactéries ça dépend
de ce que vous mangez mes résultats
votre sueur elle peut sentir la weed
alors que vous fumez pas de rides non
mais ne remercie pas
fait caca comment vous a si oui c'est
sûr que c'est la meilleure position
non vos crottés accroupi je vous
explique quand le rectum se remplit la
pression augmente à l'intérieur et c'est
ça qui vous donne envie de faire caca
mais regardez hier murs qui entourent le
tuyau là juste en dessous du rectum
il s'appelle le muscle plus beaux rectal
et quand on est assis ça tire dessus
du coup il est tendu ça fait un coup
d'oeil en tuyaux et ça passe mots en
l'air alors que quand on est accroupi le
muscle lisse des temps et ça met le
rectum et le trou de balle bien en face
vous savez comme les viseurs dans les
avions de chasse du coup le tuyau il est
sous droits et plouf direct alors c'est
vrai c'est pas facile de crottet
accroupi si vous faites ça par terre
c'est pas propre
et si vous grattez sur la lunette des
toilettes c'est dangereux mais ce qui
est important pour que le muscle soit
bien détendu c'est d'avoir les jambes à
35 degrés par rapport aux ventes
c'est-à-dire d'avoir les genoux au
dessus des hanches et pour ça il suffit
de s'asseoir et de mettre un truc sous
ses pieds pour les surélever essayez
vous me direz non non vous me direz pas
je préfère pas